very good we are in this version
google developer live in spanish broadcast
special from the technological heart of
been united in this silicon valley in
where are we going to talk to today
on the google cloud platform
specifically about open data
about open data in the region and for
what better than our expert
expert of course we have here
present with us from the
cloud platform team felipe hoffa in
which will be talking about the cases
of success some very elements
interesting and we will be analyzing
of course all the information of what
pending and the google tools and
with contribution as they contribute these
course to our regional ecosystem
so without more let's go to the presentation
from our expert today
felipe hoffa is a pleasure to be with you
conversing in today's constant
thank you for having me here very well
good good felipe I would like us
you start to comment a bit to me at all
the audience very interested in this
effect of open data in general
complexities that they have of course and
some now we will be talking
today in our interview
particular but that is the first point
that I have to keep in mind when
I'm working open data in the
open data region
let's start with tim berners-lee who invented
the impressive website 20 years ago
25 years back exactly
finally all the data could be
connected we can explore precisely
five years ago he comes to make a
talk where he says declares the success of his
first vision and gives us the next
mission is where we have to go now
and what we have to do now is
share non-raw data
said particularly speaking of that of
that felipe conference is very
interesting because there is a very
motivational inside the attentive talk
of everyone screaming is not true and
they scream because that's one of those
the questions does not make us scream gnaw
from aitana
that raw data now precisely see the
video meeting lenses tim berners-lee
about the future web or with
subtitles in Spanish if you want that is
very interesting the best part is that no
they heard this winter if he's right
government around the world are
making your data your data portals
exact public but I was actually
analyzing we were analyzing I think that
you have us to share because
you commented on governments around the world
and also in our region is
important that everyone is
aware that we have our
governments involved in the path of
exact 'open data' look here between
some for example the usa with the
first clear but not only usa
up to argentina
you have worked with good data
aires the city of colombia here you
I found in Spain clear we also have
Uruguay has a good place Lima has
your city has its data portal
and for the specific case that we are going to
see today
chile chile chile so we're going to be
analyzing the data but before
enter us into them because I know that
he was an expert in the field and all the
world that is not watching for
course, you are very interested in knowing
that you found in the portals because
basically not in detail but which
are the most common data that are
publishing the portals in general
what are the main utilities
that they are giving to governments then
let's see the chili very well but in
general that you could observe of the
data sets that you were analyzing the
governments publish everything or we have
economic information information
social housing information there is a
endless data that are interesting from
analyze correct
exact good but the main problem
that you are leaving is surely imagining
you're following us there in this
precise moment is that how are we going
those data that are available and there
we are going to ask our
expert how we started using that
information in a productive way like
we show you why are you commenting felipe
it's very interesting that there are so many
information but how are we going to start
to process and where we are going to see the
this is what you have to tell us about
What is the case that we are going about?
to see on clear day here in
chile in a portal
fixed is the pharmacy do it education
and I looked at the biggest rate that
I had basically I like
work with bit cave the database
of google that allows you to analyze in
line accurate data frames and decide
find the data is the largest in this
portal ok it turns out that is the census
15 million Chileans all
answers that gave several files
for each file in a different table and
here you can see the biggest one is the table
of people ok
every 15 million rows each with
his answer and they left three files
two 90-megapixel tablets one of 10
megas
and these data are available are
open the question is what do we do with
them exact there is complexity not
because you commented we have all the
available data that is in the portal
we can also say what is the portal
in which you are extracting the data
how is the url of the point data portal
go uve point cl ok there is all the
information that the government of chile
is obviously leaving in the in the
open data environment with a license
creative commons that allows us to
we use it share
do analysis on this exact data
what felipe did is what is
generating in all countries in this
case of chile is one but actually in
all of Latin America that you commented on
generally the world is also
running with the same licenses
You also find some other
licenses in general is a creative
commons is one of the best licenses
important that people choose in the
least restrictive license is
that's why that allows us all
be able to work with data with a lot
more exact freedom so you were
enter to the portal
you got the information as you comment
in three files but the problem that you
I'm going to start planting and here we are going to
inquire our expert towards you that
you are of course following us as
always on google I saw her in this
special version from silicon valley
of course here with felipe hoffa
the downloads have what format they are
happy everything to show this story
but I'm going to show her her life but
project all part is not true with
these three files I try to download them
we use w
by console and come on we are downloading
the exact ones it takes 22 seconds in
downloading the first type took me a minute
in lowering the three I have another in files
190 mega on my hard drive that I do with
what I do is act of buying the
points and unzipping that was delayed
about ten seconds supercomputer
that we already have about 22 seconds of
work one minute going down and the second
unzipping and it gives me a point file
that single-sided 1-point bird and we look for
the extension and we do not know what is it that
his actions has appeared efe pss
spc1 csps exact from the software that
It is used for processing
statistic someone knows someone
I have it installed now I do not have
installed you are there if you have
some you have installed surely not
happy then ok
they are open data but I can not do
nothing with them
in my first step now the next
step is how far this data
I went to the place investigate where you have to
investigate what surely
developers are imagining in this
precise moment felipe is not true
in the taco bell flow tax elector
and after several hours investigating
I managed to write a program in ere that ls
pss face and passes them to csb point too
now I have 36 and 20 tables with cc bs
with a little magic what I want
put all these columns together in one
file to magic
and if I eat you a routine in python
let's say he's going to show it to
developers or surely they can
observe at this precise moment those
magic lines of exact felipe the finger
of the 30 active ones of 1 this in a
ultrafast computer in 6 minutes
they are talking about 1.1 gigas of data
loose
and finally after giving enough
work I managed to have an active csb ok that
the government could have could have me
offered that instead of that pss
but I still have the question what do I do
with this clear now we get to the point
that we had the csb but but not
we did nothing yet all that process
it took how long to clean a
expert programmer because there are there
We do not force knowledge and want
look for meaning only time
of processing we have already return a
hour but at the time of passing
researching looking for more
exact and now how do we analyze the data
in a spreadsheet I do not think it's the best
Solution not doing so much
of data I can program without using for
example the data store load the data
in the data but it would not be either
right because we are talking about these
database concepts can also
use normal sql database and a
very clear but they will always have a
limit how fast my computer
how much memory do I have and of course I
wants to live I know her as
the expert here who knows her
diary is eyes felipe so we use my
exact leather
we skip this time the description of
my squad can watch your videos
assumptions or follow felipe in the
English version also where by
Of course there is the definition and everything
what can be done with my exact picture
but for now after these 22
minutes plus a lot of work
let's upload what is fsb to google
once it's in google cloud storage
we can import the visual data ok
I'm going to show the scripts so far
to do it the short version
perfect says the procedure
while you're working, let's say it's
also once I have sccb if I already
subo klaus now yes I'm already using
the google platform placed the data
set 6 and imported them to see exactly what
you can do by entity and you can
do by web here the writer is like
I did it by web effect three minutes
then we are ready to explore the
data that good I do not see the time and
surely to you developer that does not
they are following not only the developers
but everyone involved is also in
this technological environment that motivates
daily in Latin America in our
I wanted Latin America and in all the speech
Hispanic women are waiting for those questions
felipe
those consultations and let's see some consultations
for example how many elements we have
here I have a query in the browser
My cave was already written from
select you sing disc run the box
even though
and the row number exactly the
number of people visible how many
we have there like 15 million rows
perfect we can ask three questions
for example more complicated issues like
how religions are distributed
useful what barbarian what barbarian what
interesting that felipe and I would like
start listening to what you have for
offer us in the consultations you said
religions distributions religions in
chile is something very interesting that comes out
of the open data set data that
we have exact here I have the query
it was a small thing that not many people
You still know that you can autocomplete
in the grid that I did not know that
that I heard for example, I'm ready
here and I see the three tables that
they start consensus I will put the one of
person
column p 28 says what religion I'm going
to ask square and tell me according to
that column and we have results but
the results are not easy to read
are encoded as modified by the
exact government but Maria I have to go
to look for the schema let's say basically
that we long to see us in the same portal
of gum you can find what is the
scheme and what does each column mean by
example of 28 that we have in this case
is the religion and if we go together
the results with what it means
we can see here what are the
most popular religions and the least
popular in Chile in 2002 in
a distribution of religions very
quickly and how long it took to do
that query 15 million records
how long do we take 1.5 according to gara and 1.5
seconds
it's really impressive if really
and the grace that now you can do
interactive query without defining indexes
without making correct processing pre
for example or that we already know the
religions
How would you look for what is the religion that
is growing faster good felipe
It's super easy because in this case
we could compare the data sets but
if we have work data sets as we do
in this case we have a column that is
the number of children
then we can quickly write
a question I have here the number
average of children per religion maybe
nobody had ever seen this question
before and we can add regional
we can look for what we want
ask in this case here I have the
data divided by religion that
religions have more children and it is very very
interesting what Felipe says because
that the amount of opportunities that it gives
a set of data already placed on my leather
and basically because when you start playing
and detect and discover things that are not
there is something that many also use that
many journalists use
research is not true that they are supported
in the open data sets and start
walk or determine the strata of a
country is very interesting the concept that
it was being placed not clear happens to us
a lot are very used to us
give the data
processed do not explain us how
they simply tell us these are the
exact numbers and always ways
other than the data if they have the
raw data if they have tools to
analyze them you can make your own
questions and with virtual and what can
do freely because basically it
can register the levels but already what
you know let's say very quickly they enter
the console and there's the data set and
well let's see later but to
see I was going to ask you more let's say
how do I share but I am that you have more
surprises for us so let's continue
seeing the clear axes says two pictures
more than example each one for example
leaving the subject religions how many
children on average have mothers
according to here they are in that they are occupied
pretty interesting photos or
we can analyze it later of course
of course it is very interesting what
He also comments because women already
see how many children they have if they are
occupied in an employee in a job
traditional if they are enterprising because you
you know that there is now a current
said in very big chile let's say of
enterprising women too and it is very
interesting to see it in that sense so
or the unemployed because I think you should
have also
is the domestic service
domestic we can analyze all that very
ok with my account and we can do joyce
we also have the table of people
we have the household table we can see
as such
what tools do people use to
cook ok etc
and there technically we are going to put it to
try the expert developers who
he always said how much it costs him to see
and being a joint member in general costs
a little more structurally as you see
that when I start to link because
in the relational data it cost not
but usual and costs it does not cost
perhaps
it's still a difficult subject as
always but the ability to join two
tables of a terabyte there are companies that
they have all their sales and they also take
all the weather the record of time
for each exact day they are able to
cross that data or cross your data from
Google analytics with your sales data
with your exact usage data really
surprising
in that sense felipe and we're back to
topic too but from the point of
seen then many companies and
governments also use what they
they called and lola
the analytical let's say for that case
particular would be a solution
interesting but of course the app is a
Tremendous tool of jaén and back in
general to work what it requires is
a giant amount of pre
processing and definition of the cube
the exact dimensions in vitoria are
it is necessary once the data is
above
or you can look for any dimension that
you want that makes it super attractive
for governments in general of what
we are showing this example now
we see more of the example but for all
the developers that are us
looking and for all the fans
technological also that follow us in
this google or by live here in the
heart of silicon valley this remains
available felipe this is a model to
follow is not true that what we are
transmitting not exact take the
public data leave shipments query
nothing better than parts that can share
the Caesars
Basically you can go to your data set
find how to share it look here I have
for example the descent he
the Chilean census I will share the data
set and I'll share it with everyone
the people who can enter the eric disk
it's something to train and leather icloud.com
you can see these data that are
like the cans sets that are also
public because some that by defects
of the wikipedia of different things that
they are like public of ita sets let's say you
you can also make your data the public
this process is good what the
community a community working on
the data is open in beat query
it's not called interesting we limit ourselves not
to all the newspapers but of course
they start working on it I do not know
a better way to share data
public leave them immediately
enabled for people to do
questions for people to occupy them
that is very interesting and good at
general we were seeing then for
make a synthesis we were not seeing
how is the process that takes us from
the portal if in any of the countries
to change but as I have the data and
it came to leave it shared in bit
widely accessible query where
even I can access with clients not
certain web clients mobile clients and
start manipulating your data I already have
I want to start programming in Chile
according to hackney 12 people came to be
some of guava script joined them with
the maps visualize how the
Wow people was absolutely interesting
and have had comments to me already to go
also closing our our process
of today's day let's say what
they were the examples because they are very
interesting what happened in chile and
what do we want to invite for
course at all regional levels
to add this movement of data
open and start using these
tools that happened in chile because
there are very good applications
clark healthy this daniel fuenzalida did
together with map for what
make it possible to visualize all these
pictures on the map of chile makes
images proportional to numbers
numbers that go towards more images
large depending if there were more
amount of people in that exact region
for the question that had exact or
cristian pérez a very visualization
interesting about how people are
migrating within the country that of what
commune that as a van that's very
interesting even for governments
same because when you see him
question let's say to them
Departament say how are the
internal migratory movements or
queries that are difficult to answer
the questions difficult to answer in
minutes we could do it or in second
exact and we're done in two hours
three hours where we passed that they did not
they knew visual since I passed them the
data that used everything they already knew
over javascript maps and managed to put together
all really very very very interesting
felipe some advice that leaves you
the developers and this community of
regional developers that
permanently is enthusiastic about
google technologies
enthusiast of this movement of data
open as I knew how quickly
start collaborating what are your
tips
there are two things we can do one if
I have data is to upload it to liquefy and
share them and the other is to share this
video if they know people who have data
public and knows people what government in
the banks everything they can share
data share this video shows the
ability to see and
with this mode the world when we are the
world and with that message we said goodbye
of this special emission in the silicon
valley with team felipe josva
of experts from the cloud platform of
google in this particular case talking
of open data so keep programming
continue to develop share the
information and we continue with this
technological evolution that he proposes
our dearest region many
thank you very much thank you all and we
we see
possibly in following issues
felipe thank you very much for joining us
Thank God